so mark so far we've talked a lot about
device security and when we talk about
devices at least in my mind i imagine my
phone i imagine my laptop a tablet maybe
a smartwatch but there's actually a much
broader
uh universe of devices smart devices
things you know smart light bulbs things
we might put on things so that we don't
lose them
how does that play into this whole
notion of of device security should we
just you know not worry about the smart
light bulb or whatever else we might buy
or or or should that also be part of the
part of the picture
i worry about smart devices a little bit
and the reason is that we've now got
i just scratched myself as a comparable
in power to what was on the original
space shuttle inside that light bulb
inside that wall switch now for the most
part they're not doing that much they
don't have access usually to your data
you know if it has a camera or something
that's another issue but literally for a
light bulb the biggest concern is that
it has access to your home network it's
on that same wi-fi with your laptop and
your phone and your tablet and they may
be sharing sensitive information
so for that reason what i tend to do is
to not buy the absolute cheapest light
bulb i can find because those companies
with their very thin profit margins
often don't update that you know tiny
little computer that's inside the light
bulb so it may have vulnerabilities it
may have weaknesses that hackers can
exploit there are actually a few
examples of that happening so in this
case what happened is somebody found a
vulnerability affecting
millions and millions of light bulbs and
switches and smart toasters and what
have you
and they were able to get them all to
wake up at the same time and to hit one
particular website until that website
was overwhelmed and couldn't keep up
with with the traffic that's called a
denial of service attack and so by doing
that they were able to use lots of
innocent people's smart light bulbs and
smart toasters to do some real damage so
scary scary crimes not affecting the
person in the house but affecting you
know some victim down the road
again the best solution to this is
getting devices that are updated and
patched that do receive those same
security updates that you get on your
phone or your laptop and most of the
reputable brands you know certainly the
google nest devices but most of the
reputable brands will have those
security updates so you'll be in a
pretty good place there